[Music]
welcome back as you can see I am in a
fabulous outfit that's right when you're
wearing a Victoria Beckham suit well
that's what you do
um I mean her signature style has always
had you know what I wonder if I can do
this actually oh God this is
everybody please welcome Victoria Becca
[Applause]
am I doing it right you are doing it so
well I mean hi this is amazing I mean
you're gorgeous oh my God
[Applause]
it was amazing oh my gosh I'm so honored
to be with you I'm so honored to be in
your clothes I'm so honored to talk
about your extraordinary beauty line
have you always known how to take care
of yourself you know I think that
um it's about balance and you know I I
take what I do very seriously I work
really really hard but I think it's
about getting balance you know I really
do think so and eating healthily and
working out where possible and just
having a good work ethic as well your
work ethic does seem infallible and
that's why I think it was so exciting to
watch you at Paris Fashion Week you know
you've been doing fashion shows for many
years your label has been a juggernaut
success thank you but this was the first
terrorist Fashion Week that you did it
was I mean
thank you this this was such such a big
deal for me I mean you know fashion is
my passion I feel so lucky to have a job
um that doesn't feel like a job I just
love it I love dressing women and making
them feel like the best version of
themselves and for me post post pandemic
to to have a show in Paris was such a
big deal such a brand moment for me well
okay I have to tell you almost every day
we have a segment called Drew's news and
almost every day on the show we've been
talking about space world 25. okay
what were the conversations to get
everybody on board and back together and
put out this album that there is such an
my eyes just crossed there is such an
appetite for
I mean we're just celebrating I think
it's 25 years since since the group and
you know I'm so thankful and grateful to
the girls and and the fans I really am
you know I loved being a Spice Girl I
loved going on tour thank you for
putting that out into the world because
I think that it was not just fun and
celebrated it was so meaningful for
people we love seeing women working
together it's just that thing that you
know and you are taking care of women
not only back then but now the way you
talk about you know enhancing a woman
her confidence her gait her inner voices
you know that's what makeup does I think
makeup is a tool yeah to get yourself to
bigger and better thoughts go beyond
yourself yeah how are you liking being
in the beauty game we are very kind
thank you you know it it really is my
passion and for me I've always been so
involved it's not just about putting my
name on products you know I like to come
up with the ideas I'm in the labs with
my team you know I'm a bit of a control
freak you know I'm creating products
that I want to have in my makeup bag and
I just love what I do and I want to make
women feel like the best most gorgeous
version of themselves and what I want to
create is a luxury fashion and Beauty
House of the future that is what I want
to do what
I've been playing with your eyeliners
the this one's my very favorite because
I always have wanted a color just like
this it's like snakeskin disco like
green this is so these colors are so
complementary to the eye pupil and the
color of one's eyes I have to say that
alcajao eyeliners are phenomenal I mean
we struggle to actually keep them in
stock because they are so so popular
um you know what's very important to me
is not just inclusivity but
sustainability and using clean formulas
and I think what people love about Alka
gel eyeliners is um is that they are
clean and the wear is absolutely
phenomenal and once you create your look
they're going to really really last you
which is great and we've recently just
released three new kajals my favorite is
sequin green which I love it's uh that's
this one that's this one here yeah
that's my favorite it's great this is
such a hard color to find all right we
have to cut to a quick commercial break
I don't want to but we'll be right back
with more Victoria Beckham
[Music]